ja dimanche les téléspectateurs ont
l'habitude de se retrouver devant leur
magazine d'information sept à huit si
l'émission traite l'actualité de la
semaine cette fois ci le magazine de tf1
a fait un choix qui à semer le trouble
parmi certains téléspectateurs le
docteur henri iv il profité de sa
consultation en gynécologie pour
agresser sexuellement ou violées
certaines de ses patientes en effet
dimanche dernier la chaîne a donné la
parole aux gynécologues bernard henric
tristement médiatisé pour avoir été
accusé d'avoir agressé sexuellement une
soixantaine de ses patientes je sens
qu'ils vendent on sait que des files
tient procédure qui a débuté il ya sept
ans et qui n'a toujours pas été jugé
c'est notre ans présumé innocent que
bernard henry qui a témoigné dans sept à
huit je ne comprends même pas ce qu'ils
me reprochaient au micro du magazine
l'homme clame son innocence parce que
j'ai jamais fait ça simplement parce que
j'ai jamais fait ça est-ce que vous
pensez que ça je m'en souviendrai pas un
parti-pris étonnant de la part de la
chaîne dont certains s'interrogent sur
la raison d'entendre le témoignage d'un
accusé d'abord que la justice ait pu
faire son travail
alors c'est vrai que la question est
posée est-ce que c'est pas un peu
prématuré butelle justice n'a pas pu
aller au bout de l'instruction
le livre m'a prématuré j'ai envie de
dire surtout scandaleux en fait c'est
scandaleux soixante victimes
potentielles c'est pas juste une ou deux
personnes qui veulent faire une vendetta
personnelle j'imagine à l'encontre de ce
médecin c'est qu'il ya forcément eu des
choses un petit peu bizarre que les
choses c'est plus qu'un faisceau de
soupçons comment dire oui quand même on
est d'accord et de voir que le monsieur
en fait est interviewé qui passe à la
télé dont qui la limite 1 un droit de
réponse est un droit de défense face à
tout ça moi ça m'a scandalisé nommé sam
est totale mais encore retarder un droit
de réponse aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui il est présumé innocent pour
l'instant il n'a perdu son procès donc
il a le droit je suis désolé de pouvoir
y arriver une émission depuis damas il
ya des victimes peut-être
aujourd'hui il n'a pas été jugé donc
heureusement qu'il a une droit de
réponse comme annoncé mais la question
c'est est-ce que ce que c'est vraiment
utile départ de tf1 de très simple faire
second prélat alors qu'elle est victime
d' en plus qui seront abordés des images
de victimes que les benjamins pour pelé
du coup il aurait fait ce reportage sans
aussi la parole de ce médecin qui est
accusé il a aussi son vin répond jusqu'à
présent il n'est pas accusé jusqu'à
présent il n'a pas été déclaré coupable
jusqu'à présent il n'a pas été incarcéré
donc heureusement qu'on lui donne la
parole je suis désolé un an
on va regarder juste
le témoin ya justement d'une jeune fille
qui a retenu notre attention regardez
il était debout les mains sous
la table j'ai senti 20 son sexe et déjà
il vient
donc là j'essaie de me relever j'ai vu
qu'ils regarder vers la droite qui me
regardait même pas et là
[Applaudissements]
je pouvais pas bouger déjà l'été dans
moi j'ai pu sentir encore fait puis tu
dis ça y est il est en train de même
joli que je crus pomme défense je peux
rien faire
donc là évidemment ça complique encore
plus la séquence et on lui donne la
parole moi je veux bien qu'il soit
présumé innocent mais quand vous avez 60
témoignage du même acabit quand même
c'est la limite de la décence plutôt que
d'autant qu'après d'autant qu'après on
lui donne la parole il vient avec sa
femme et ils l'expliquent face à son
explication de son combat contre cette
pseudo accusations c'est moi c'est une
autre regardez si au départ le
évidemment le ciel me tombe sur la tête
c'est difficile mais d'un autre côté je
suis tellement serein sur le plan que je
comprends même pas ce qui m'est reproché
est-ce que vous pensez que ça je m'en
souviendrai pas là ça veut dire que je
suis vraiment dément c'est à dire que
j'ai fait quelque chose comme ça et je
m'en souviens part je n'ai absolument
pas aucun doute sur son innocence
on le vit comme
comme un cancer
donc on se dit que c'est notre cancer
rôles combat
angie je suis pas en train de dire
attention que je crois ou que je prends
parti dans ce qu'il est en train de dire
bien au contraire simplement c'est juste
sur le fait voilà aujourd'hui il n'a pas
été déclaré coupable donc il a le droit
de s'exprimer maintenant ça veut pas
dire que je crois que monsieur ou que je
crois que ces versions ne se croit pas
la question d'un procès ce que c'était à
tf1 de faire ce sujet là comme ça en
mélangeant anna les bases des pâtes et
du coup c'est potentiellement très prisé
et des gens qui visiblement ont été
témoignés
lui plus plutôt que d'interroger pour
nous la question pourquoi ça prend
autant de temps pour juger des faits
aussi graves c'est sûr alors plutôt
peut-être intéressant c'est que du coup
comme il peut toujours exercer pas la
gynécologie mais l'endocrinologie au
moins certaines femmes pourront se dire
n'allons pas rencontré cet homme parce
qu'on sait qui il est et surtout
ses côtés son épouse on peut le voir
aussi qu'elle est dans le déni est aussi
sous influence et l'ordre des médecins
ne le condamne pas ça aussi c'est très
grave il est toujours parader mais
évidemment on va évidemment le rappeler
parce que ces principes il est bien sûr
présumés voilà donc affaire à suivre
enfin si jamais il est condamné
il ya un truc intention c'est également
le défunt est dans l'obligation de les
donner la parole c'est à dire que la
partie au moment quelqu'un et près de
1900 une rédaction et c'est la loi qui
est comme ça est dans l'obligation de
demander la réaction de la partie
adverse tant qu'il n'y a pas de jugement
qui n'a au maintien c'est lui qui a
demandé c'est la loi d'accord de tout à
son secteur n'avait pas fait la demande
lui peut porter plainte pour diffamation
ou pour d'autres pour d'autres pour
d'autres faits de toute façon c'est même
du procès médiatique écoutez la victime
est ce qu'on appelle le défendeur et
sont dans leur rôle d'un fou et sautez
pas besoin d'être intelligent que tf1
donne la parole aux deux parties donc 7
à 8 on peut leur reprocher beaucoup de
choses mais ce n'est pas une émission
qui manque d'éthique donc je pense que
ça ne me faire après notre baiia pas
besoin de lévis qui a besoin de savoir
ce qu'il fallait faire ça maintenant
alors là c'est tout après les gens ils
ont donné la parole aux deux parties